[موسيقى]
قبل حرب روسيا عاده اوكرانيا كانت الدول
الاوروبيه تشتري الغاز بصوره جماعيه
للحصول على اسعار الافضل كانت روسيا
المزود الرئيسيه للقاره لكنها خفضت
امداداتها من الغاز في اعقب الحرب تحول
الاعتماد الاوروبي الى دول اخرى في العالم
ابرزها الولايات المتحده فارتفعت اسعار
الغازي في منازل الاوروبيين بشكل قياسي
يسعى القاده الاوروبيون الان الى تخفيض
فاتوره الغاز في منازل المواطنين لكنه
مختلف لشهور على تحديد اسعار الغاز اتفق
الاوروبيون اليوم على سقف سعر لا يتجاوزوا
180 يورو لكل ميجا وات في الساعه يعني ذلك
انتهاء خلافات استمرت شهور اذا كانت
المانيا وهولندا والنمس واخرون يتحفظون
على الفكره من اساسها فيخشون من يمتنع من
تجول الغاز عن ارسال الوقود والاتجاه الى
زبائن اخرين تهدد موسكو على الدوام بالرد
على محاولات الاوروبيين تحديدا سقف لسعر
الغاز وهو رد بات منطارا الان تقول اوروبا
انها خفضت اعتمادها على الغاز الروسي من
49% الى سبعه في المئه من اجمالي
احتياجاتها بهذا تطوي اوروبا شهورا من
الخلاف على تحديد سقف لسعر الغاز لكنها لا
تنهي ازمه التوفره في منازل الاوروبيين
وهم ينتظرون شتاءا قد يكون قاسيه